Scottish actor Gerard Butler first came
to the attention of the masses of king
leonidas in the 2007 epic 300 bursting
onto the Hollywood scene in a blur of
muscle and blood
zack snyder's take on Frank Miller's
popular graphic novel became a huge hit
with audiences diggin the unique style
of action and the finely crafted
physiques of Leonidas and his Spartan
warriors but was too much of the acclaim
heaps on the cast butler in particular
of the real test would come after 300
when the leading man would be forced to
cover up his text and do some actual
acting so far
Butler seems to have had some trouble in
movies where he keeps his shirt on and
he is why late bloomer Butler came to
acting relatively late in his life and
at times it shows the Scotsman didn't
even consider becoming an actor until
the age of 27 when he saw a production
of Trainspotting at the Edinburgh
Festival and decided he wanted to be up
on stage himself he was working at the
corporate law firm after graduating from
Glasgow University with a law degree
though he was fired a week before he was
scheduled to be promoted from trainee to
solicitor due to his erratic behavior
Butler moved to London to pursue his
dream and landed a part in the
production of Trainspotting that
inspired him to leave the legal
profession in the first place returning
to the Edinburgh Festival the following
year as part of the cast it was the
start of his journey to Hollywood
stardom though the time he spent
training to become a solicitor rather
than an actor has left him at a
disadvantage the skills that it takes
most top actors years of hard work to
fine-tune may not be present in him and
of Butler seemingly limited ranges
further exposed with every role he takes
his options become equally limited
accidents accidents one skill that
Butler hasn't been able to develop
though not for lack of trying is how to
mimic accents well I'm actually from the
state I just practicing my Scottish
accent for foreigners making it in
Hollywood
usually depends on whether or not they
can produce something close to an
American accent yet Butler can't seem to
go more than a few sentences without his
broad Scottish brogue breaking through
and giving the game up
an American dialect isn't the only
accent who's had trouble with either
despite having been exposed to it
throughout his youth by Irish family
members the actor personally apologized
for his butchering of the Irish accents
in the 2007 romantic drama PS I Love You
box-office blunders the alternative to
having blood slur adopt an accent is
allowing him to keep his Scottish one
though this doesn't always work out for
the best
either jabs of Egypt's director Alex
Proyas discovered that first hand
Pryor's was too busy apologizing for the
whitewashing of a film set on the
African continent the field less serious
questions about Butler's accent though
numerous critics questioned why an
Egyptian god sounded like an extra from
Braveheart accent aside but the status
of an a-list leading man was on a
knife's edge in the lead-up to 2016
Scott of Egypt and the film staggering
losses served as proof that he doesn't
seem to be much of a box-office draw
critical drain train well he and the
rest of the cast certainly took it on
the chin for gods of Egypt it wasn't the
first time Butler has felt the wrath of
critics the year 2016 was a particularly
bad year for The Scotsman with pretty
much all his projects universally panned
low-key drama the headhunters calling
failed to earn any respect and his
actions he called London have fallen
didn't fare much better hamstrung by
allegations of casual racism and the
poor reactions of Butler a Secret
Service agent Mike banning of course
none of this is anything new to Butler
seeing as his films are rarely reviewed
positively in fact is Rotten Tomatoes
filmography features 34 films with just
5 awarded the coveted certified fresh'
rating and 23 of them scoring 50% or
lower on the tomato meter cgi reliance
unless you count 1997 Tomorrow Never
Dies where Butler had a minor part in
the Pierce Brosnan Bond flick only three
Gerard Butler films have managed to
break that golden $100,000,000 barrier
in terms of lifetime growth and those
were DreamWorks animated smash hit How
to Train Your Dragon How to Train Your
Dragon 2 and 300 all three of these
films rely heavily on CGI in one way
another and the facts Butler has only
managed to find this level of success
thanks to the works of talented
animators begs the question can Butler
carried the load when things are
stripped down to the bare bones rom-com
stomp it wasn't too long ago that every
other phrase searched on Google was
Gerard Butler 300 workouts and that
physique is still the only thing that
pops in your head today when you hear
his name Zack Snyder's fantasy epic
launched Butler to stardom and set the
stage for a career as an action hero but
the yank to decided to go in the
opposite direction while he kept up the
tough-guy
active appearances and guy ritchie's
rocknrolla and crime thriller lore
abiding citizen his most notable roles
in the years that followed 300 were in
romantic comedies PS I love you the ugly
truth and the bounty hunter were all
slammed by critics and failed to
transform his tough-guy image into any
kind of heartthrob status behind the
scenes letdown the 2013 presidential
action thriller Olympus of fallen was a
real labor of love for Butler a film he
was passionate about and involved with
from start to finish
Butler told the independent that he
worked so much on the script ripping it
apart and putting it back together
really putting flesh on the bones of it
and trying to give it some real
substance and meaning in terms of a fun
action thriller that is going to be a
rousing experience he also revealed that
he tries to separate the nasty and mean
comments from the constructive criticism
when it comes to reviews though he has
his work cut out for him there not only
as a film star but as a writer and
producer too unfortunately he had to
wade through a lot of bad to get to the
good because Olympus has fallen was
criticized on almost every level luckily
it still performs well enough at the box
office was born a sequel and to get at
least one more shot to see if audiences
want to watch a third thing for what's
next what's next for Gerard Butler well
more of the same from the look of it The
Scotsman filmed an action flick called
Hunter Killer in 2017 where he plays a
submarine captain tasked with rescuing a
president although this time it's the
Russian head of state
kidnapped by terrorists and yes angel
has fallen the third film in the fallen
franchise is still on deck for release
in 28
despite the fact that the previous two
films were railed by critics
reviewers might talk but money works and
most films made enough money at the
worldwide box office to justify
squeezing one more adventure thriller
out he'll also once again provide the
voice of spikes The Fast and How to
Train Your Dragon 3 slated for 2019 so
we haven't heard the last from Gerard
Butler just yet thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]